blues clues star Steve Burns was pretty
much every late 90s kids pretend best
friend as he took them on colorful new
mysteries around the house and outside
with his trusty pooch pal the show which
centered on Steve and his dog Bloo
making an interactive adventure of even
the simplest things like checking the
mail ranked right up there with popular
contemporaries like Barney
the Teletubbies and Winnie the Pooh so
when Steve suddenly disappeared from the
hit program and was replaced at the
height of his popularity the rumor mill
went haywire even going so far as to
declare the young show host had died to
explain his unexpected departure
luckily Steve is still alive and well
even though his former fans might not be
able to spot him walking around town I'm
completely unrecognizable now what he's
been up to since taking his leave of the
small screen might just surprise you
here's what's become a former Blue's
Clues star Steve Byrnes exit signs the
obvious first question most people have
about what happened to Steve Burns is
why did the guy leave this show right in
the middle of its prime no he didn't
have some other lucrative offer luring
him away nor did he fall into a pit of
depression but he did start to lose his
hair and watch some behind-the-scenes
creatives take their leave too so for
him it was just time to go when he did
there were also a few practical
considerations at play it was crazy
and it was awesome but it was it was not
exactly the kind of thing that I would
think would ever get me a date one of
the other factors that had Steve
questioning his reality while he was
such a central kid show icon is whether
the wacky messages he was delivering to
so many millions of little ones were
actually worthy of their attention you
can do anything that you want to do but
I couldn't help thinking you know is
that true still alive Blue's Clues might
have come along during the advent of the
internet age but pop-culture urban
legends still loom large at the time
somehow rumors spread like wildfire that
Steve died of a drug overdose or a
grisly car wreck in between seasons four
and five even though in the last episode
of season four
Steve introduced his own replacement
Steve's brother Joe played by donovan
patton for the final two seasons of the
show in 2017 he spoke to tech insider
the persistent death hoax to be rumored
dead for 15 years starts to feel
disturbingly like a cultural preference
nowadays burns makes light of the rumors
with the Twitter handle at Steve Burns
alive 2 both have fun with a
misunderstanding and clear it up making
art although Burns hasn't nearly
reclaimed the same level of fame that he
had on Blue's Clues
he hasn't shelved his stack of old
headshots entirely just yet
he appeared on stage for the moth to wax
poetic with a true life telling of his
time as a children's TV show star and
also starred in The Flaming Lips weird
space centric holiday video he's also
been starring on webisodes of small
YouTube shows like the professionals and
even appearing alongside another Blu
storytelling pal for bizarro Studios
Herman's scary stories series of course
those cameos alone probably aren't
enough to pay the bills and as Blue's
Clues residuals can't last forever I
wanted to know how you've been doing
with my money well broke so Burns has
been steadily moving forward on a music
career he's been working on for so long
all the while
[Music]
he fulfilled his own childhood dream by
releasing his own record and when his
solo act wasn't hacking it he linked up
with the Flaming Lips alum Steven Drozd
to begin working on an album thanks to
the popularity of Blue's Clues with a
producer's kid Steve was well known
before he ever made his big pitch
hey it's not like he hadn't shown off
his skills on the show already the two
have since formed a project called
Steven Steven and put together a trippy
kid's album called for everywhere which
drops in February 2017 free time
although his music making and random
acting jobs are fun enough Steve burns
also has enough time to bring his fans
in on some of his other obsessions like
taking pictures of every Walmart sign he
sees and yes even the occasional bit of
nostalgia in ponds about his former life
as Steve of Blue's Clues although the
show is now far in the past for Steve
Byrnes he does have a few reminders
lying around the house for old times
sake the chair sits in my in my study I
love it I have the original notebook I
have the first three clues which is cool
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to